مسامير وصواميل وضعت داخل 6 ثقوب في نعل
كل حذاء جعلت الماكينات الالمانيه تعمل
بكفاءه عاليه ليست ماكينات في مصانع بل
اقدام وتركض في الملاعب هذا ملخص ما حدث
في نهائي مونديال عام 54 الذي وصف بمعجزه
بئر حذاء حرما مجرى من الكاس في الدقائق
الاخيره واهدى اللقب لالمانيا وهو نفس
الحذاء الذي كان السبب في شهره عالميه
وثروه الملياريه لهذين صاحبين شركتين
اديداس بوما فما قصه هذا الحذاء الذي قلب
كل موازين المباراه
منتخب المجر كان مرشحا قويا لنيل لقب
المونديال في سويسرا عام 54 اما منتخب
المانشف فقد شارك على استحياء بسبب اثار
الهزيمه في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
مدرب المنتخب الالماني وقتها لاحظ ان
قدرات اللاعبين البدنيه تقل بشكل ملحوظ
عنده هطول الامطار في الملعب
سيبهار برجر كان له صديق في قريه المانيه
بعث له رساله يشتكي له فيها انه طول
الامطار بغزاره سبب كثره انزلاق لاعبيه
داخل الميدان وطلب ان يجد له حلا سريعا
هذا الصديق كان يدعى ادولف داسلر حرفي
ماهر في صناعه الاحذيه ويمتلك مصنع صغيرا
عرف لاحقا بمصنع
اديداسنر ثم بدا في التنفيذ فقبل الاحذيه
بسته ثقوب في قاعده كل منها ولم يكلفه
الامر سوى مثقب يدويا وسته مسامير ثم ثبت
كل مسمار بصاموله ووضع طبقه عازله
الحذاء المزوده بالمسامير فاعجبه ثم ذهب
لشقيقه رودو وعرض عليه الفكره فقام الاخير
بتجربه الحذاء في ساحه المنزل المليئه
بالطين وكانت النتيجه مبهره
ادولفا صنع ثلاثه وعشرين زوجا من الاحذيه
ثم ارسلها لمعسكر منتخب المانيا خاض
اللاعبون بها المباراه النهائيه التي
شهدته طول امطار غزيره لكن المسامير ثبتت
اقدام المنشر
ثلاثه اهداف وسائل الاعلام الالماني ووصفت
هذا اليوم بالمعجزه في بايرن نسبه الى
مدينه بايرن التي شهدت المواجهه اما وسائل
الاعلام المجهريه فاتهمت اللاعبين الالمان
بتناول المنشطات لكن السر كان في مسامير
وصوالي
تم تكريم الاخوان
ضخمه واطلقاها على مصنعهم الصغير لقب
اديداس
بعد شهره الواسعه التي اكتسبها الاخوان
داسلر قرر الانفصال ادولف اطلق شركه
الجديده اديداس وهي اشتقاق من اسمه الاول
والاخير في ما جرب رودولف في البدايه كلمه
روضه فلم تلقى استحسان الالمان ليغيرها
الى بوما لاحقا لكن المنافسه التسويقيه
بينهما تطورت للخصام الذي استمر لاخر
حياتهم فلم يتصالح مطلقا لدرجه انه عند
وفاتهما دفن جثمانه كل منهما على طرفي
الكنيسه ليكون ابعد ما يكون عن بعضهما في
الحياه وفي الممات